this man rubbing shoulders with the
likes of Natalie Portman Paul McCartney
and Rihanna is French business Mogul
banar Arno while he might not be as
recognizable as those three he's got
more money than all of them combined I
know is the world's richest person with
a net worth of 191 billion dollars at
the start of 2023. he is one of the most
important businessmen in the world
certainly the most important in France
right now
he is the CEO of lvmh Moet Hennessy
Louis Vuitton which is basically the
first word in luxury in addition to
Louis Vuitton the conglomerate includes
Brands such as Dior Tiffany's and
Belvedere Vodka luxury for me is how can
you create desire he's been in charge of
lvmh since 1989 and all of his children
have powerful roles within the business
here's how bonarano built his wealth and
how he plans to keep it under family
control
the richest person in the world isn't a
tabloid Mainstay or red carpet regular
even if he is seen on the front Road as
Bran's fashion shows he's a guy who is
somewhat shy he's even even maybe a tiny
bit awkward there's a saying which gets
repeated to me constantly by uh French
billionaires and French CEOs which is
cashier which basically means to to live
happily you have to live hidden the
beginning of the Arno Empire starts with
an acquisition which would become
something of a modus operandi for him
over the next 30 Years in 1984 he took
over busac the holding company that
owned French fashion house Christian
Dior
and the most well-known fashion name in
the world he sold off pretty much all of
the group's Brands but Dior and pulled
it out of bankruptcy
in the late 80s dior's Revival helped
darno amass a stake in the recently
founded lvmh of which he soon became the
majority shareholder CEO and chairman
over 30 years and several Acquisitions
later ldmh now includes 75 Brands
covering wine Jewelery hotels and
fashion
the European company has also expanded
into China and the US where are no once
joined then president Donald Trump at
the opening of a Louis Vuitton Factory
in Texas he's a great gentleman a great
businessman and he's really an artist
to me Bernard is an artist and what he's
done is incredible the luxury giant now
has a market value of nearly 438 billion
dollars and revenue last year was around
86 billion dollars
these results have boosted our nose
wealth and put him above the likes of
big Tech billionaires such as Elon Musk
and Jeff Bezos while those men have seen
their company shares drop in recent
months lvmh's share price is up over 165
percent since lows in March of 2020
though the stock market is apparently
not something Arno pays attention to
um
that price boost was thanks to Surge and
demand for luxury goods during the
pandemic when affluent Shoppers were
stuck at home flushed with cash and more
recently China's loosening of strict
covid-19 rules the country is one of the
luxury industry's biggest markets
himself has a ton of legitimacy because
he built up this company from scratch he
built this Empire through several
battles he's obviously involved in all
the key aspects of the business also
involved in key aspects of the business
are his five children who are often seen
with him at Brand events let's meet the
family
I know married his first wife and a
wavrin in 1973 and they had two children
Delphine and Antoine
Delphine is the newly minted CEO of
Christian Dior while her younger brother
Antoine is CEO of the Family holding
company
after divorcing Anne Arno married Helen
Mercier and had three more children
Alexandra holds an Executive Vice
President position at Tiffany's the
American Jeweler lvmh took over in 2021
Frederick his CEO watchmaker tank Hower
and Jean heads up marketing development
for Louis Vuitton watches
more than 97 of the oil which in turn
owns 41 of lvmh
family also owns close to seven percent
of lvmh directly
on top of that they have total voting
rights of more than 60 percent so
essentially what the what the art knows
and what Bernardino himself decides goes
in that company and I know has taken
steps to ensure his family retains
control over the empire last year lvmh
voted to raise the age limit of its CEO
meaning the 73 year old Arno could
remain in charge until he's 80. if he
wishes he also changed the structure of
the Family holding company the children
will each have a 20 stake in this
structure and they can't sell their
shares for 30 years and it essentially
will keep the shares in the family even
beyond that and it's one of the kind of
favorite pastimes in Parisian Business
Circle to to kind of watch his his
children and track their progress with a
view to succession I know has not
publicly named a successor but whoever
it is will inherit a company that has
successfully navigated the pandemic amid
concerns for the future of the industry
High inflation and the war in Ukraine
have prompted estimates of a Slowdown in
luxury good sales in 2023
and in China a recent wave of covert
infections means life there remains
disrupted
economists also haven't ruled out a
global recession for now though at least
the luxury markets wealthy customers
seem happy to keep spending the luxury
goods industry has been a good one for
investors in part because Global wealth
every year is rising and so more and
more people coming into the luxury goods
Market each year and that's Obviously
good for for lvmh for banana and for
people selling luxury goods
foreign